Brewing this holiday season at the Four
Seasons and it's going to benefit the
Smith Center here in Las Vegas and here
to tell us more about holiday tea is
Carrie Noonan the food and beverage
manager from Four Seasons Hotel Las
Vegas and the president and CEO of the
Smith Center for the Performing Arts
Myron G Martin welcome you to Middle
initials and everything oh hey we are
official here I'm telling you it's great
to have you both here and this this
spread looks amazing and this is just a
sample of holiday tea at the Four
Seasons tell us a little bit about it
absolutely yes thank you for having me
back it's a pleasure to be here uh yeah
this year we're really excited at Four
Seasons Las Vegas we're bringing back
our annual holiday tea so it's a really
great traditional kind of afternoon tea
but this year of course for holiday
theme for the season and I love it
because not only do you have something
for the kids you've got the sweets the
pastries the delicious stuff with
champagne maybe for people definitely
champagne for for the grown kids for the
grown-ups yes so we have all of our
traditional kind of afternoon tea you
have your sweets your sandwiches your
scones you have your spreads of course
your selection of teas adults a glass of
champagne upon arrival and then also
available for kids as well that is so
much fun and and how how do people get
uh be a part of this how do you make
reservations definitely and you can
either give us a call
702-632-5121 or you can visit the Four
Seasons Las Vegas website and make
reservations through there as well now
Myron I love that the Smith Center is a
part of this and you guys actually
benefit from a portion of their sales
tell us a little bit about that well we
do and how how great for me because you
know this this is the place I go for all
the holiday meals I love the Four
Seasons I've seen you there before the
holidays yes you have but to spend the
holidays this this year and have it
benefit education programs at the Smith
Center as you know we do a lot with kids
we've we've greeted over a million and
students at the Smith Center since we've
opened and so this
partnership with the Four Seasons means
we're going to do more of it and it's
going to help benefit the heart of
Education Awards which Happens Every
Spring right here in Las Vegas honoring
the greatest teachers in town you really
do the Outreach you do for
for our teachers in this community is
amazing is there any specific uh thing
that you just keep in your mind that
you've seen money like this go to to
help kids oh oh listen we could do like
an entire hour about how kids are
impacted by the Arts but I'll tell you
this when companies like the Four
Seasons come to us and say we want to
partner with you it says that that
people appreciate the fact that we're
touching kids lives well you guys do it
like no one else at the Four Seasons and
again if you want to make your
reservations just reach out to the Four
Seasons and how long is this going on
until
um it will be through December 17th on
Saturdays from two to four in the
afternoon you gotta check it out so good
I'll send it over to you Jillian